[Musique]
bonjour à tous les deux merci beaucoup
d'être en direct avec nos sur rt france
alors il ya eu ce coup de théâtre hier
soir alors qu'on s'attendait à une
longue nuit d'examen du texte suspension
de séance donc voté à main levée mais
que s'est il passé pierre cabaret
vous savez il s'est passé à un mauvais
coup de cette antienne politique qui est
là et qui qui ennuie tout le monde alors
évidemment on peut s'enorgueillir
d'avoir fait un coup politique de la
part d'ea l'air mais on peut surtout
être réaliste et se dire que ce n'est
pas un coup politique c'est un mauvais
coup pour les français et c'est un
mauvais coup pour la santé des français
et je crois que ça tombe bien compris
les républicains c'est vrai on crée la
surprise puisqu'ils ont voté cette
suspension alors que les députés
s'étaient montrés favorables à ce passe
vaccinale qu'en pensez vous pierre
frédéric boyer c'est un coup politique
uniquement
oui vous savez le vieux mons et c'est
pas ce genre de coup politique le vieux
monde c'est de considérer que
l'assemblée était juste une seule
d'enregistrement que le débat n'est pas
permis alors moi je partage pas ce qui a
été dit par jean luc mélenchon qui est
dont l'excès complet qui compte le passe
avec ce final sanitaires etc vous êtes
un type absolument ridicule par contre
je pense qu'il ya il faut savoir il ya
une sorte de soulagement de plusieurs
parlementaires qui voulaient plus de
temps pour la réflexion en commun sur le
pass vaccinale et les questions qui se
posent le passage final pour qui quelle
tranche d'âge qu'est ce qu'on fait de
nos adolescents dans quels lieux va-t-il
pouvoir se mettre en place et c'est moi
je pense aussi qu'il faut plutôt
positivement le seul député il faut
prendre le temps d'avoir une réflexion
commun savait que les républicains ne
sont pas contre le post vaccinale mais
il y avait une sorte de course en avant
qui poussaient un peu les choses
peut-être que la conférence des
présidents le va permettre aussi d'avoir
une réflexion en commun là dessus je
pense qu'il faut prendre un petit peu de
temps ce que la tranche d'âge et où il
va être comment dire exercé se passe
vaccinale et la sortie du post
vaccinales sont des vraies questions il
ya 700 amendements je crois que à vue
deux cents ce qui est très bien mais
soyons raisonnable pendant un peu plus
de temps je pense que même dans vos
rangs monsieur le député je crois que
certains parlements tat souhait de voir
qu'il y avait beaucoup de temps pour la
réflexion en commun est-ce qu'il faut
plus de réflexion pierre cabaret est ce
que le 15 janvier prochain les français
seront soumis au pass vaccinale a priori
à partir de 12 ans
d'abord je ne suis pas de ces députés
qui négligent le le le débat est là ils
ont négligé débat parce que nous avons
nous les députés l'habitude de rester
aussi tard que possible pour mettre les
grands sujets sur la table il se trouve
que la loi sur l'avortement vous savez a
été votée à 3h40 n'a jamais été votée
sans débat là c'était vraiment éliminer
le débat ce qu'ont fait les l air est
inacceptable ce que cette vieille
politique vous pourrez toujours dire ce
que vous vous laissiez ciel n'a en en
tout cas on bossera on bossera cette
nuit s'il le faut et la nuit prochaine
s'il le faut aussi mais se passe
vaccinale est absolument indispensable
pour la santé des français pour les
protéger alors j'entends dire évidemment
et compris chez les nerfs que attraper
et transmettre est toujours possible
avec le vaccin évidemment attrapé
travail et transmettre est toujours
possible avec le vaccin mais lorsque on
attrape et on tranche mais avec le
vaccin effectivement sans le vaccin on
se retrouve en réanimation et on fait
quoi en réanimation 1 on utilise des
lits est on est on risque sa vie
donc c'est complètement inique ce qui
s'est passé est irresponsable je le
répète je leur dis vous êtes fous et
qu'ils apprennent les réactions
je vais simplement un bond à monsieur le
député si monsieur le député considère
que le pacte vaccinale est un élément
extrêmement important il est dommage que
les députés la règle et était largement
absent d'hémicycle vous voyez donc
c'était comme une question importante
vous avez été mis en minorité par ce que
vos collègues parlementaires de la reine
était largement absent de l'hémicycle
alors on peut faire la vielle tambouille
politique comme vous voulez faire lancer
de la polémique si vous voulez mais j'ai
besoin un discours positif de
construction ensemble de quelque chose
qu'on peut faire ensemble dans l'intérêt
des français disent pas ce que vaut
perdre 24 heures monsieur députés que le
pass vaccinale va être une catastrophe
quatre heures c'est absolument faux faut
pas dramatiser les choses on travaille
en commun et je pense que justement ce
député il faudrait avoir une réflexion
en commun pour trouver virer un
consensus dans l'intérêt des français
pour montrer que sur ces questions
fondamentales
on est en construction
intelligente et collectives voyez donc
on peut faire la veille tambouille on
peut s'envoyer des piques si vous voulez
où je sais le faire vous savez le faire
mais ça n'a aucun intérêt tout ça on a
l'impression que ça devient hautement
poétique on est en campagne la
république en main je comprends
maintenant à valérie pécresse la
majorité l'accusent d'être responsable
si ce texte a été suspendu pierre
cabaret c'était là elle la bonne
occasion de s'en prendre à la candidate
de la droite qui talonne emmanuel macron
dans les sondages je crois que ça ça n'a
rien à voir là bas vraiment rien à voir
on va pas mélanger delà de la politique
et de la santé au mieux tout ça ensuite
peut pas députée valérie pécresse
et sait pas qu'elle ait même pas député
c'est que lé président d'une grande
région monsieur billet et je j'apprécie
ce que vous dites d'ailleurs et je hais
je conçois qu'il faut absolument
travailler ensemble et c'est dans ce
sens là pour travailler ensemble et dans
le meilleur des débats que la présidence
hier soir avait été donné à la
présidente a l'air de l'assemblée
nationale est vrai c'est dommage que
les galères et pu
négliger ce débat au delà de minuit
j'aurais préféré qu'il se passe mais
vous aussi je pense que vous auriez
préféré qu'il se passe même temps dans
la nuit mais qu'on puisse tous débattre
de ce sujet en toute tranquillité en
toute quiétude et c'est un sujet qui
effectivement fait débat non seulement à
l'assemblée nationale mais dans le coeur
de son ancien et ce car là il faut pas
le négliger ce carla et dans lincicome
permettre
je vais me permettre une idée parce que
il faut être bien conscient de la
situation vous avez l'eau oms a sorti un
rapport il ya quelques quelques semaines
sur ce qu'on appelle la fatigue
pandémique c'est un rapport qui est
extrêmement intéressant que je vous
invite à lire si vous l'avez pas lu et
qui explique bien que les français dans
le monde entier notamment skis les
français ont besoin d'une lisibilité de
sortie de crise et vous le voyez par
exemple les annonces la veille de la
rentrée scolaire son nouveau protocole
cette espèce d'insécurité juridique
sanitaire etc c'est extrêmement
compliqué moi ce que je vous dis c'est
que à temps supplémentaire 24 48 heures
pour remettre les chaussures sur la
table les rênes des rapports qui est
carré d'angleterre sur le microbe qui
montre que oui c'est plutôt bénin qui à
peine surcharge sur les hôpitaux etc il
faut qu'on soit raisonnable il faut
qu'on soit très pragmatique il faut
surtout qu'on s'autorise au bout de
quinze jours à moi de revoir notre
position sur le passage final on peut la
dg il ya le temps politique et le temps
des études médicales qui sortent est
décédé parfois dissonant donc soyons je
pense raisonnable
comment un peu plus de temps c'est pas
dramatique je vous assure on regarde les
chiffres sur la réanimation en français
sont plutôt stables moi je le vois
surprise non le droit je le vois ça
n'évolue pas depuis un mois voilà je
pense qu'il faut surtout pas faire de la
politique avec ça il ya eu un coût des
nerfs parce que je pense aussi que dans
vos rangs aussi il faut le savoir il ya
des flics sont pas complètement à l'aise
avec ce qui se passe pour ceux qui
avaient beaucoup d'absents aussi mais
prenons le temps faisons le de manière
plus sereine soyons exemplaires
voilà je veux pas lancer de polémique
là-dessus mais je pense vraiment pour
les français ce serait bien qu'on puisse
se travailler ensemble intelligemment et
que le différend aussi revoir un peu sa
position parfois qui est un petit peu
rigide qui nous met un peu les portes
sur des amendements des suggestions de
l'opposition
et vous à ceux qui disent que cette
crise sanitaire ce regain épidémique en
tout cas d'eau mikron
visa a occulté en tout cas la gestion de
cette crise visent à occulter le débat
politique en ce moment pour la campagne
électorale non je crois que je crois que
c'est un mauvais débat c'est faux et je
crois que d'ailleurs monsieur le maire à
a évité ce sujet là et je crois qu'il en
a raison
vous avez dit dans nos rangs il ya une
union dans nos rangs savez très bien la
veille il ya une union dans nos rangs
tout ça il ya une union autour de cette
réactivité et vous avez raison vous
citez l'angleterre
on te prend tous les exemples du monde
mais cette au micro nous a eu de façon
assez inattendue et inattendu sur chaque
pays et dont sigler donc on a une
réactivité et vous avez raison monsieur
le maire de dire une chose et
je vois par la mère qui est sur le
terrain autant qu un député peut l'être
aussi mais c'est vraiment formidable
vous avez raison il faut donner cette
espérance et je crois que cette
espérance on ne la donne pas par un coup
politique
mais pour un camp par alcan 106
politique c'est pour ça que j'ai rejoint
emmanuel macron en 2017 pour ce
consensus politique et je crois que là
là dessus nous sommes absolument
d'accord c'est vrai vous avez raison
aussi il faut donner le temps de la
réflexion et le temps du dialogue mais
ce temps de dialogue il est donné et il
est malheureusement donné la nuit parce
qu'on n'a pas beaucoup de temps pour
réagir et lorsque vous dites aussi que
depuis à moi il ya une stabilité moi
j'ai l'hôpital de purpan à toulouse sur
ma circonscription
y'a pas une stabilité ça augmente un peu
tous les jours ça passe un peu ça aurait
augmenté mais finalement et mesures que
nous prenons sont en rapport avec la
dimension épidémique que nous craignons
donc
crois que
sur la dimension on s'en doute il faut
il faut aller vers un consensus sur le
coup politique non et sur le coup
politique de dire emmanuel magnien
krouma pécresse non je crois que là la
joie on est on est pas encore rentré
dans cette dans cette campagne et dans
une compagne qui ne veut pas à l'équipe
réduire les français enfin c'est ce
serait en tout cas c'est pas le cadre de
la république en marche que de ne pas
vouloir rentrer dans ce
décret sera d'eric billets à mot à mot
pour finir est ce que est ce que c'est
devenu un enjeu de la campagne cette
crise sanitaire selon vous alors vous
aurez remarqué que jenny cité dans les
bacs rond ni valérie pécresse dans mes
propos si vous les verrez gratitude une
femme de qui est extrêmement responsable
qui connaît très bien le terrain qui
fais pas de polémiques avec ça
simplement effectivement il faut se
donner du temps il faut qu'on arrive à
trouver un consensus monsieur le député
vous avez tout à fait raison le temps
des débats qu'on assène sans abonnement
à travailler en une nuit il faut pas me
faire croire que le débat peut être
complètement serein voilà en plus ça
vous avez la malchance d'être entouré de
parlementaires et les filles qui sont
dans l'excès total
url et ça simplifie pas le débat j'en
suis tout à fait conscient mais ce
serait quand même conscient que les
républicains les parlementaires
républicains sont parfaitement
responsable ils ont voulu mettre un coup
d'arrêt au sila parce qu'il faut prendre
le temps de la réflexion faut le prendre
manière très positive ils ont faire un
coup politique si vous voulez simplement
ils ont appliqué le règlement je peux
vous dire que monsieur macron h et un
coup politique avec le drapeau européen
sous l'arc de triomphe foyer je pourrais
aussi petite polémique ça n'a aucun
intérêt l'intéressé et s'ils ont trouvé
un consensus ensemble que les français
soient rassurés sur la gestion de la
crise et sont tous sur la sortie de la
crise ça c'est essentiel à repriser les
débats a priori ce soir merci beaucoup
en tout cas à tous les deux d'être
venu en direct à distance
malheureusement en tout cas pour
débattre de cette question merci